so thank you very much for the
opportunity of the presentation
so today i will be presenting about the
ganges water conflicts between india and
bangladesh which is actually one of the
major boon of contents that's happening
between the two neighboring countries
so i would be speaking about
it is basically it follows three
three flows the first part would speak
about
from where the problem originated and
the second part would say that uh what
is the present condition and the third
part we'll discuss uh which i think
would be the most relevant part for our
class that is the water diplomacy part
on how we can actually approach that
problem and how we can uh
try to find a solution
so let me go to the next slide
so i would be putting a little bit of
disclaimer uh some part of my discussion
might not match with bangladesh
government's official view so i would
this is important because
because of years of training because i'm
not an academic because of years of
training uh two things happens the first
one is
subconsciously and i have found it even
when i've taken classes in japan or in
the us that's uh automatically i
actually
reflect the views of a typical
bangladeshi bureaucrat the particular
government's a point of view it is very
i had to train myself to i mean stay
away from that view and try to match
with the academic standard and come up
with as much as objective point of view
as possible so here
i would try deliberately i mean
not to match the typical stuffs that is
saved by the bangladesh government or
any government
per se so that is one thing so
and the second part is uh the political
history because although it's a
treaty it's a river treaty but it is
very sensitive both for bangladesh and
india and the political history between
bangladesh and india has a sort of
influence in this whole discussion so
knowingly or unknowingly sometimes that
political history will
visit us in my
my
presentation so
with these two disclaimers i start my
presentation
so
first a little bit of history and
geography
so
you all know about the indian
subcontinent that there are many
countries it was basically under the
british rule for 200 years and before
that it was 600 years under the mughals
of the or the muslims
so
before 1947 at the left most the huge
map that you see total blue
this is the
situation of indian subcontinent and in
1947 uh right after the second world war
the indian subcontinent was divided into
two and that is after the partition in
1947 you can see the green part still
stays
the india the the present-day india and
the orange part deep orange part that is
uh
on the upper side it's west pakistan and
on the
lower side this small country it's east
pakistan which is the modern-day
bangladesh
so in 1971
we had a
we had a war against the western part of
western part of pakistan uh it was
actually very natural you see that there
is like almost
2000 miles gap between the two parts so
it was sort of obvious for many reasons
so in 1971 uh this
first one single country that is india
second india and pakistan and after 71
it became three countries that is india
pakistan and bangladesh
so
this is the case
and here uh
i'm bringing this little bit of a little
bit of history to explain the
relationship dynamics of bangladesh
india because without bringing the real
estate dynamics between bangladesh and
india it is
kind of tough to understand that how and
why this treaty is so sensitive
so here we can see that in 1916 december
1971
you can see this is the surrender
ceremony this is the surrender ceremony
of the occupying force in 16 december
and in the left side three million uh
people that is the official number
bangladesh claims uh it is disputed but
uh this is the official number that it
was killed so there was
we said that there has been genocide and
murder which happens almost in all the
words so this is the surrender ceremony
and there is an interesting fact you
will see
that
in the left side someone who is signing
for bangladesh this is an indian indian
general uh general jagat singh aurora so
you can understand the historical
connection between india and bangladesh
it's very deep and it used to be
during the liberation war
india india directly helped us
militarily and later after the
independence which both the parties
considered that both india and
bangladesh should be very friendly
but
after the after the independence that
actually changed and major anti-indian
sentiment has been present there and one
of the reasons this happened is that
the the
the the
pharah
dam which has created serious trouble
for bangladesh and for that gradually
there has been some treaties and it was
so serious uh that let me explain the
basin a little bit first so i would be
reading from an article by either roman
so
this is the dangerous water basin you
can see that from here the
the ganges is coming and coming and
coming and it is entering from the
hugely hugely falls in the
west bengal so previously before the
partition uh bengal was uh united so
there was no east bengal or west bengal
so after after the partition uh one part
of bengal fall into india we speak the
same language our culture is almost same
the religion is a little bit different
religion uh the hindu majority is in the
western part the west bengal and the
muslim regulations in the eastern part
because the partition happened for the
two nations theory that the muslims will
be living in pakistan and the hindus and
other villages will be living in india
so that was the theory but that didn't
work so
here when when we speak about this uh uh
ganges uh water basin we would speak
about the ganges river the ganges river
originates in the central himalayan at
the altitude of uh seven uh seven
thousand ten meters and extends into the
alluvial
gangetic plains and drains into the
indian ocean at the bay of bengal
the ganges is a trans-boundary river
which has a total length of
approximately uh 2600 kilometer and a
total catchment area of
1 million eighty seven thousand square
kilometer
the river basin spreads occurred across
india nepal china and bangladesh where
india shares the major portion which is
79 percent of the total basin area and
in contrast bangladesh is the furthest
downstream country of the basin and
shares only about four percent of the
base in area which nevertheless
represents 37 percent of the total area
of bangladesh
uh
the hydrological cycle and water
resources of the ganges basin are
governed by
a southwest moonsoon are characterized
by high temperature heavy rainfall
strong seasonal variations the region is
characterized by flooding in the wet
season which is due to october
and water scarcity in the dry season
which is november to may and during the
muslim season there is an abundance of
water but during non-muslim season a
lower precipitation causes a reduced
flow in the basin the insufficient
supply of water in the downstream during
the dry season causes significant
socio-economic impacts
through disruption to the agriculture
fisheries forestry and navigation of
this of this region so here
we can see a little bit more details of
the close-up that the ganges river that
is he entering here is the farah kadam
and here it's it's it's
ganges entire enter bangladesh
through the the west bengal the hoogly
area river and it enters and it becomes
pogba which is the biggest river in
bangladesh also which is the
economically most significant river in
bangladesh
and
the impact you can see in the next
picture you can see that in the in the
lower part which means this part this
whole part this this ganges delta the
lower part the
the ganges river when it enters
bangladesh it becomes pogba and
any
change in the flow or any climatic
change or any man-made change has
serious impact in the lower region of
the southern part of bangladesh and
i actually have seen uh directly because
uh my home hometown is actually in the
bhagavata area which is in this region
so
although it's like anecdotal experience
but i can actually see that like our uh
village area it was
it was actually very uh full of flora
and funa but with time it actually
reduced and now that when i go to go to
the village after like five or ten years
we see that it has totally changed so
this actually matches with the academic
articles that i've read here so
what are the major water diplomacy
events between bangladesh india since
1971 as you know that
in 1971 bangladesh became independent
and india had direct help india debate
contribution towards that so in 1972
right after uh bangladesh became
independent in 1971 december and in 1972
the bangladesh father of the nation
straight medieval roman and indian prime
minister uh indira gandhi they sat down
water was actually an issue back then
what was actually an issue back then
between india and pakistan uh especially
this far far akadam the ganges river
water sharing treaty so
for the first time this actually sat
down immediately after uh immediately
after the independence in 1972 which
actually shows that how important it is
for this
for the region to maintain the peace and
tranquility between the two countries so
the first joint water commission between
india and bangladesh was established in
1972
and
this newly made joint water commission
between india and bangladesh actually
tried to survey and they tried to
determine what are the course of actions
that can be taken because for decades
decades for india pakistan rivalry no
development actually happened so in 1974
uh
it was declared by that commission that
there was this joint declaration to
resolve water sharing issues the
existing issues that were there but in
1975 uh bangladesh
was killed with his family and there was
a kudeta and the military took over so
in 1976 uh india unilaterally withdrew
from this declaration
so after uh after this happened in 1977
there was this temporary five-year
treaty which ended in 1982
uh which started in 1977 during the
bangladesh national party regime which
is the which is uh historically
considered as anti-india
so in 1982 it was not renewed and after
that after long break in 1996 uh there
was this treaty between india and
bangladesh which is a ganges water
sharing treaty between bangladesh india
which was signed by
uh dev gorda the veteran prime minister
of india and the present prime minister
of bangladesh uh sheikh hasina
so
this is more or less the major
developments and there is this uh
interesting uh interesting uh fact that
is there
that
from india to bangladesh 54 rivers
actually come and bangladesh is in the
downstream and india is in the upstream
54 rivers from india bangladesh is a
rivalry country there is like hundreds
of rivers 54 of them actually comes from
india and it is spread in bangladesh
throughout just like a net
but unfortunately so far there has been
only one treaty uh one proper treaty
which is the
the ganges water treaty we treat sharing
and out of uh for last quarter century
there has been no treaty and
another water treaty that this water
treaty there has been many talks but
still there has been no development so
we can actually understand that why we
are speaking about this ganges water
sharing treaty and and its significance
so what do we find in 1996 what a treaty
between bangladesh and india
so
this was the treaty this is the very
very minimum that treaty was there uh
the the first uh the first the the first
uh the sharings the sharing calculation
was like this uh 70 000 accusex or less
water when it's available uh 50 will go
to india 50 percent will go to
bangladesh if it's between 70 000 to 75
000 the india will maintain the balance
of the flow and the the bangladesh will
have remaining at 35 000
and 75 000 q6 or more when when there is
water availability uh 40 000 q6 will go
to india and bangladesh will maintain
balance of the flow so that was the uh
basic uh that was the very basic and the
very minimum of the water sharing water
treaty between bangladesh and india so
what are the real scenario i mean this
is the treaty that we have got but what
is the real scenario so here we can see
the real scenario that bangladesh has
been frequently deprived of its minimum
share during the most critical periods
of the dry season and which has caused
the loss of agricultural land we created
problem in salination the wellness of
the people has decreased and which has
created uh such a huge issue that in
every election that bangladesh happens
this repeatedly comes
and during the march 24 to 31 the 10-day
cycle in in the year 2010 the actual
release to bangladesh was 44 lower than
the indicated release and in 2016 the
situation became even worse than that
even worse the actual release during
march 20 to 31 was 47 percent lower than
the indicative share followed by a
further 34 percent and 49 percent
decrease of flows during the other
alternate critical periods so we can see
that whatever
that is written there in the treaty uh
unfortunately this is not
the real scenario is very very different
uh which is why i mean
we have to look into this issues very
seriously and we have to decide because
this is going to end in 2025
this is 2021 and to
if it is not renewed uh a very different
scenario might happen we don't know what
is going to happen but now is actually
the perfect time to think about this
particular scenario and think of
different possibilities especially
especially from the conflict resolution
point of view
and what are the
problems with the treaty that we can see
that it underestimated the impact of
climate variability the frequency of low
flow events and increased water
extractions upstream
and the future climate change and higher
upstream water demand were not predicted
and also in several locations neither
bangladesh this is very interesting that
i was speaking about the problem that is
that bangladesh is facing but uh
a few articles actually indicated that
the treaty was made in such a way that
in several occasions uh not only once
not only twice but several locations
neither bangladesh nor india was able to
receive their respective shares as i
stipulated as stipulated in the treaty
and
some other other problems that can
discuss with the treaty is that
bangladesh frequently did not receive
its fair share during the most critical
periods of the dry season when water
demand is relatively high in both
countries
and there was no guarantee clause for
bangladesh in no guarantee cluster of
bangladesh which would ensure that
i mean although there is treaty but if
bangladesh does not get
there is no guarantee uh that is insured
for bangladesh so that became another
major problem and the opponents of the
current government they used to say
things like uh there is no guarantee
which means this is get just to show off
so which also created huge political
turmoil in bangladesh scenario and it is
evident that the advanced hydrological
models were not used and
because if there was uh i mean there was
advanced hydrological models were not if
our advanced hydrological models are
used uh the prediction would not be i
mean creating so much trouble uh if if
there was uh
if there was deliberate error then maybe
one side would be benefited and one side
uh would not be benefited but
unfortunately the standard was set in
such a way it shows that none of the
countries several times do not get what
they are supposed to get according to
the treaty so uh some of the authors
like said islam he actually questioned
the the hydrological models that has
been used to
deal with the treaty and he also claimed
that the advanced models finally used
which is why
the treaty is in the pen and paper but
in real in reality the
the quantitative
distribution of water has not take place
properly
so this is uh we can see uh there are
some picture two pictures actually that
i've picked that what happened during
the
what happened during the dry season so
bangladesh is a country which is uh
which is i mean which used to be full of
blessings from the nature a lot of i
mean you wouldn't see dry lands very
often but after after this marriage
actually happened and during the dry
season this actually happened and
what happened is the poor farmers i mean
many of them actually
lost their lands and they had to i mean
some of them actually there has been
cases that some of them could not even
survive physically they couldn't survive
and many of them in those areas they
left their lands and they came to the
capital city and which is why after they
came to the capital city they didn't
know anything about agriculture but they
started to find a job they didn't find
it so they tried to
do other things which they didn't work
and
at one point what happened that crime
rate increased very high because these
people they cannot survive in their area
and they come to the capital city or the
big cities and they start coming they
start a career in crime
so that is how actually indirectly even
with that
even with the crime perspective even the
law enforcement perspective uh this
faraka is actually affecting bangladesh
so
let's uh let's see the ground realities
so now that we will we will enter in the
into the third part of our presentation
which is the uh which is that the water
diplomacy part so let us check out some
of the ground realities the first of all
i mean
india has economic political
geographical and military advantage and
not only that uh
it has been
very few i mean for last last almost 15
years the present government is
in the power and they have very strong
tie with indians and
many of the many of the political
experts they say that without india's
support and backing this government
would wouldn't probably survive so some
of the political scientists they
actually come up with that that sort of
analysis so i mean whether this is true
or false there is a separate issue but
uh one thing that is clear that a huge
uh huge population a i mean a major
population group they actually believe
this and once they believe this they
automatically have the anti-india
sentiment and india by cashing out on
this sentiment even the political
leaders they also get paranoid they also
think that if we try to take any
decision that does not directly go in
favor of india maybe india will try to
pressure pressure the bangladesh
politics and the bangladesh political
leaders will
lose their seat so with this fear uh
very very little instance said there
that bangladesh actually confronted
india and i'm sure that this situation
is not uncommon in other parts of the
world so
also like in 1971
india was directly supporting bangladesh
to become independent their their
soldiers actually died with our freedom
fighters so what happened that
when the war ended immediately there was
a there was a joint joint commission
initiated but uh
it is very unlikely that that sort of
warmth of relationship between the two
countries is going to come back in the
near future and even there is a strong
political will there is animosity uh
both from bangladesh bangladesh side and
indian side and as i say that there is
very strong anti-indian sentiment
currently waving in bangladesh and this
feelings is mutual due to the political
scenario both in india and bangladesh
the present present government in india
they try to
they are a populist government and there
is
us versus them this sentiment is being
very very much played in india and also
in bangladesh so these are the ground
abilities so what are the things that we
can do that is uh what that is i'm
trying to try to portray the
the first water diplomacy approach that
i try to try to find is the finding
common grounds what are the common
grounds uh that we can say because
bangladesh actually stand no chance by
confronting india saying that you have
to give us india would you say that like
well we wouldn't give you do whatever
you want
so here this international water
management institute so from there i
actually i actually
brought this and so these the issues
that we can see that low dry season
fresh water flow the increasing
siltation accumulation of sediments
water resources along the areas of the
river basin are depleting the small
rivers and the distributor is getting
dried and disconnected a reduced length
of waterways used for negotiation and
reverberate erosion formation of
formation of dry lands and the
socio-economic vulnerabilities so the
problems that has been there gorham is
actually a variant of a variant of the
genghis river on the middle side inside
of the bangladesh and howard river is in
the west bengal another river so
these common issues that is actually
there both between india and bangladesh
so the joint water commission that we
have and in our water diplomacy syllabus
what we have studied in various times
that
an emphasis on joint water community and
finding the common ground and finding
the common challenges uh is very much
stressed in water diplomacy so i think
these are the issues that happens both
for india and bangladesh during the
during the
dry seasons in in west bengal and in in
bangladesh so these are the things that
that both the parties can discuss and
they can try to share some common ground
which they which can be exported and
that is how the treaty can be uh
the treaty can be uh i mean upgraded so
another water diplomacy approach is the
indicating india's own problems with
farakka this is a 2017 newspaper article
with some references so there is this
indian chief engineer he actually
discussed when this plan was happening
in 1961
so he actually uh pointed out some
various problems for example the drought
and the climate change these are the
things he he actually uh pointed out to
the indian government he's a he's a
bengali guy krishna
so he actually pointed out those
problems but back then
his carrier took us he was a chief
engineer
on the west bengal side then this far
academy was happening and when he
indicated those problems for example the
different parts of public tools for the
districts and we have the the flooding
the drought and the change of
biodiversity and the salinity issues and
also the annual seed silk region
from 6.4 million uh
cubic meter to 21.8 million uh cubic
meter till 2003 so this sort of things
happened and these were actually
predicted so
this problem not only it's from an
academic report this was so serious that
the bihar
in the bihar area
some very influential politicians the
chief ministers and they actually saved
the central government that why don't
you i mean demolish the farakadam so the
way bangladesh wants a solution for this
problem
even some parts of india
there actually wants the same so when
there would be a discussion maybe from
bangladesh's perspective this india's
own interest can be exploited uh and
come come to a middle ground
and this is something which bangladesh
repeatedly failed that india became
repeatedly successful bangladesh since
uh after the uh 1982 uh where after 1982
when the
when the
another party which is uh historically
considered as anti-india they came to
power they tried to internationalize the
faraka situation they tried to i mean
the sarp was built and then this issue
was taken but india was actually
stressing that no this is a bilateral
issue but if you look at the basin you
will see that there is china bhutan
nepal and bangladesh well bhutan and
nepal their cases exactly like
bangladesh but
the surprising new scenario is that now
that china has global aspirations
china
more than once they came out with with
the tista river which is another river
in the northern part of bangladesh they
came up with the proposal that we would
help you with the technology and the
money so that you can build another
branch on another side so
this became another bargaining chip for
the chief for bangladesh
that using the the china factor i would
i'm using the china factor and building
an international uh the
the joint commission is the joint
commission can be international it needs
not to be bilateral it can be
international bringing china since the
china is actually trying to provide
bangladesh some with some new options
and uh they are actually saying that
china's water weapon that is the word
they have used so
the this is uh this is this is the
concept that i've borrowed from uh the
cipher stumps are the the slams
uh the bringing other bargaining chips
that is not usually uh considered for
example uh this is bangladesh on the on
the left side the west bengal is there
you can see the jharkhand bihar and this
is nepal bhutan this is bangladesh and
you see a huge part of india is actually
there and the majority of the border is
in
is with bangladesh and there is
i mean
sentiment there is strong sentiment
against against the central indian
government because it is very much i
mean it is called the seven sisters and
the seven sisters uh well
this is far from the central government
and which is why the control is very
much i mean not as strong as delhi or
the nearby states so and many of these
states they actually want independence
of their own and
which is why and even when uh
at present bangladesh and india has a
very strong tie because of the
historical results the present prime
minister he when his whole family was uh
killed uh for six years he actually
lived under the indian production so it
is considered that she would probably
never go against the interest of india
but when anti-indian sentiment
comes with a new political party there
is always threat
that this part of india would be very
much tumultuous there will be terrorism
and many of the
terrorist leaders many of the
nationalist leaders of those parties
they actually i mean they used to
operate from bangladesh and one famous
incident that i can say that in 2004 uh
10 trucks 10 truckloads of uh 10
truckload of
most advanced military weapons were
passing towards bangladesh but uh
it it was a fluke that it was caught so
it became a huge case so
i mean it can be a huge trouble for
india so this particular issue can
actually can be brought in the
negotiation table by uh say by saying
that well uh we would provide you full
support with safety and security of your
uh the seven sisters part uh in exchange
uh maybe we can discuss about the the
sharing of the water treaty so this is
another this is one bargaining chip
which i think can be exported i i tried
to see that check the literature but uh
so far i haven't seen that bangladesh
has went through that path and another
another uh
cheap can be
there are some articles from the indian
sides they actually claim that the
bengal bengal means the west bengal they
need pista and the tista we have a
barrage in this we have we have a
diamond pista and still uh there has
been many talks but so far there has
been no treaty so
i mean although we are speaking about
the advancement of gandhi's treaty the
upgradation of genji's treaty maybe uh
the tista river to get some advantage in
ganges river treaty bangladesh actually
can think of discussing with india
whether they can bring this uh this
tista river treaty treaty with them as
well tista is very sensitive because
tista is actually it has originated in
sikkim which is very close to china and
this is the river especially for which
the chinese the chinese actually offered
bangladesh a technical support to bring
bring further dams and by doing that
changing the course of the river so it
became a very serious issue between
bangladesh and india and the diplomatic
diplomatic talks are still going on so
these are actually the steps that we can
think of
using as the bargaining chips so that
a new joint commission can be made and
the
the things like climate change and other
the other problems which was not
considered in 1996 can be considered now
because uh in 30 35 years
in 30 almost 30 years the technology has
changed the gps has come and many other
the scientific scenario has changed so
maybe by bringing all these things
together a solution a better solution
can be saved and
before i finish with all the criticisms
i would actually uh i would actually
again say that which i i feel and i also
read from the ahmed's article
that this this ganges water treaty is
probably
uh it is not perfect it is definitely
not perfect
but if it was not there the situation
for both the countries would probably
worse
so the treaty should be there and we
should try our best to
we have four years maybe we can try our
best to think of the
the advancement of the treaty the the
and also
addressing the
addressing the limitations that we are
currently facing thank you very much if
you have any comments and if you have
any questions i'd like to answer them
thank you very much
thank you um for the nice presentation
um
so um now i would like to ask um
others to make comments like aaron and
jemma do you have any comments or
feedback
thank you mushroom for a really great
presentation i i learned a lot um
i really appreciated how much sort of
geographic and geopolitical context
you've brought in i thought that was
really helpful
um
and i really
liked the sort of back third of your
presentation where you really kind of
thought through all of the water
diplomacy framework elements um
so yeah great job i think my
feedback um as you're thinking about
writing your paper
would be
there's
i was a little confused at times about
sort of how the treaty has failed to be
implemented thinking about like
um
most
most specifically around like how
neither country is able to receive
um their respective share as it was
stipulated in the treaty is that
technical problem is that a diplomatic
problem
um
i think you could maybe identify like
where the specific sort of limitations
or weaknesses of the treaty are in terms
of how that actually is sort of
manifested um
on the ground
so that's one thing to keep in mind um
yeah i don't know if you could talk
about that at all like are there sort of
technical flaws or
political flaws um that might be sort of
helpful to understand
uh well uh the technical flaws uh i i
actually
accept my limitation i'm not really a
technical guy i tried to read some
technical papers and i actually read one
of professor on animation's paper which
gave me some insight so the one
technical paper that i read they said
that
uh
in last thirty last two decades almost
last two decades
f very few
i mean
very few papers or very few research has
been done to actually trying to quantify
the quantify the
the amount of water that has been there
one of the reasons was there but
initially the historical data was not
there for example in first five years
probably i mean first one or two years
the the type of precision that you need
to get
to
to predict that what is going to happen
through the history now that we have it
fortunately because it has been it has
been quite long so uh the research has
uh already started so maybe i will try
to put that
and the diplomatic
the diplomatic problems that you are
saying that uh
one major problem that i can say i mean
since this is an i would never say this
outside the classroom
that
for example uh
us
it has a national policy
the government changes
but the policy
the the main theme of the policy remains
maybe some sides changes but if you have
to change the main theme of the policy
for example u.s has a defense policy
right us as a defense policy that we
would do this we will do that how we
would do that maybe that can be
discussed
and maybe different different
governments can do it in a different way
so in india of course indian democracy
is not as strong as the u.s or the uk
but in india
in some basic factors for example the
the defense or whether they would share
this or that they also have some sort of
policy they also have some sort of
strict policy that even though the
political
government changes uh this uh this
doesn't change much and they strongly
uphold the constitution and one of the
reasons is that there has not been in
the history of india more than 60 years
from 47 to 2021 more than 60 years uh no
military
takeover was there and because of india
is so huge military takeover is actually
not not very much feasible but in
bangladesh it's a country 50 years of
age
out of 50 years
more than 15 years there were military
governments and i would be very blunt
here at present we also have some sort
of autocratic government and the system
has become such that uh i mean it is
very tough for bangladesh to come out
from this political so when you speak of
diplomacy we have some wonderful
diplomats really well trained diplomats
but the decision actually comes from the
politicians i would not blame them they
definitely have their point of view but
uh due to this lack of political culture
of having a straight aim
i mean
it is like i mean uh total one
government comes so far before the five
or ten years one policy was going uh the
government changes it goes backwards so
it's zig zag zigzag so
i mean
it is it is an issue but uh thank you
very much for the
for the input because i would try to
address these things especially uh
specifically maybe i wouldn't be
speaking too much about diplomacy
because i work for the government and
they read those papers and
but the technical uh technical part
maybe i will seek help from larry and
professor gein uh to include more the
technical parts in in my paper thank you
very much
hi mushroom um i also wanna echo i
learned that huge amount of presentation
the question the question i have and
perhaps you address this somewhat but i
like to speak more to it maybe i missed
it but is does the current does the
current treaty have
um
[Music]
uh
like how does it manage water
measurement uh and and the processes for
actually determining how much water
there is different times of year and how
much water there is over time because
you talked about the ways in which the
amount of water has
has changed partially as a result of
droughts and and the different
pieces of infrastructure that have been
built um but i'm interested in in
what
if there's any
ongoing uh collaboration or
shared effort or even even individual uh
kind of national efforts to
quantify how the water
both quantity and quality is changing
over time
well i do not know very details of the
technicalities but i can give you some
very basics which is there on the treaty
so
the geography of the two regions is more
or less same
and
the west bengal and and bangladesh so
although we are speaking of india india
is a very big country right so 28 states
but ultimately uh bangladesh and
bangladesh shares with west bengal from
where this the ganges river comes so
i mean by studying the
by studying bangladesh or by studying
west bengal
a very basic idea actually
can be found for example the dry season
in bangladesh from january to may it is
same in west bengal
and and and the
under the west season in bangladesh
which which falls up to december so
from from july to december that is also
that is also same same in
both the parties so
the join the joint committee they
probably use some hydraulic models to
to actually uh set the
amount of water for example it is uh
70 000
cubics the the basic standard is the
first one is as if if there is 70 000 uh
cubic seconds
q sec the the
the unit is q sec if seventy thousand q
sec is there both the countries will
share fifty percent fifty fifty percent
so the uh this is how they have made and
from seventy to seventy five uh so there
would be
the the balance ratio would be for india
and bangladesh would get a minimum at 34
000 q6 and
if it's 75 to 75 and above above then
the same kind of
ratio is there
so
this much is there for example you
mentioned that there have been years in
which neither side has gotten the
amounts they've been allocated has there
have been any ongoing efforts to you
know if there's if there's under 70 000
to quantify how much is flowing
um and yes
i i think that bangladesh we have we
have an agency bangladesh indian water
trust
england water authority we have
bangladesh water development board so
they actually conduct some scientific
studies and based on those
uh
i would be i would be honest with you
that those the government organizations
i mean for example the scientists uh
scientists who have that sort of
expertise
the bangladesh
those organizations are not really the
most lucrative jobs for them
so we do what we can and sometimes we we
bring foreign from consultants and with
those uh some studies studies are made
and based on that actually uh this this
sort of distributions are made but then
again uh
there are flaws in this uh uh um
i think in terms of um
measurement uh the joint river
commission um is um so there is joint
collaboration between india and uh
bangladesh
river commission is responsible for
measuring the things so in in terms of
theory both the indian side there is a
joint rival commission and in the
bangladesh side there is a joint river
commission so both parties
they um in terms of in theoretically
they
measure and in terms of um
dry season period they measure the flow
and they agree on that so i think in
terms of agreement they do have this
kind of things but
in reality this kind of collaboration
although they exist but
this kind of enforcement is they rely
only on the indian side that
maybe they don't regularly go to the
faraka point to measure the things but
they
i think
the the way that india and john river
commission communicate to the bangladesh
joint river commission they agree on
that kind of measurement so that's the
idea
i was actually looking for some articles
uh whether the
the state water department i'm not sure
that whether
the indian states have separate
water
departments or not or whether it's a
it's a federal i'm not sure so i try to
find whether there is any collaboration
between not only the state level but
also the
not only the not only the federal level
but also the
state uh the the west bengal state and
and bangladesh but uh probably i i i
i probably missed i didn't find in such
collaboration
so is there any other feedback that um
you would like to
bring like councilman or um
a spline
oh
mesh roof congratulations presentation i
learned a lot from you today thank you
um especially the visual was very rich
your presentation i just have one quick
suggestion because you said that you are
not going to mention a lot about the
diplomacy because you are part of the
government
but if you re when you read the the
larry's book that specifically page one
three three one 133
he mentioned about that
water manager and his stakeholder can
approach
uh to the to the conflict using the
traditional way or they can use the
non-zero sum approach and i think that's
very interesting if you can
include in your in your final paper
yeah specifically they talk about the
water management
that's following two category categories
a high
can enforce a decision or the other
parties themselves can negotiate a
settlement
that formal third help to implement i
think this this chapter is very
interesting for your presentation thank
you very much
thank you very much
yes
yes
thanks for the presentation um
i'm hoping
that you can
synthesize
the diplomacy discussion in the final
version of the paper
and it would be wonderful
if you had a one page
introduction
to your discussion about diplomacy
that highlighted
two or three ideas
about
what's new or different
with regard to diplomacy
that could be tried that hasn't been
tried
without going into all the explanation
in this summary
of how this would be done
but to just highlight
you talking about bargaining chips
you're talking about linking other
issues it's it's a lot
um
pick two or three things
that you want to suggest that are new
and say
i think the focus should shift to
involving
all of the states
and not just the national governments
okay if that's
if that's one of your proposals
then state that as a as an
a a new emphasis
that should that might change the whole
story
if you think as aaron was implying
that
a new approach to joint measurement
would provide
timely and believable information in a
different way
and that with that information
new joint management
under different sets of circumstances
would be improved
even if the treaty isn't changed
then say that
but not more than two or three ideas
that could be expressed in a couple of
sentences
as the
contribution
to your discussion about diplomacy
because otherwise it's too much
okay it's impossible
to follow all the different lines of
diplomacy that are implied by the
different maps and the different
bargaining chips and
the different relationships and what
might be done and
it's it's just too much
just choose
two
no more than three but even those two
uh ideas about changed diplomacy and
highlight those okay
i know that you have lots of other stuff
but i think for the paper
the power of the paper will be improved
if you zero in
on just a couple of ideas about changes
in the diplomacy
going forward that haven't been given
enough or the right attention in the
past
professor in that case maybe i will try
to
speak about
the
i mean one point that i that i said
maybe
instead of three or two i will just
focus on one
that is the
the
bargaining chips the alternate
bargaining chips maybe i can choose just
this one and go deeper on that what do
you think i i think that
there are different bargaining chips
that are more or less attractive to one
country or another and that instead of
saying bargaining chips is one thing
i would specify the bargaining cheap
pick one bargain in chicago which ones
which i mean i thought the idea that you
have all these states they're not happy
with their own national government
it's possible
that a negotiation involving those
states could change what gets talked
about and shift the balance of power and
provide an opportunity for a
sub-regional piece
of the treaty to go ahead
so that's about bargaining chips but
it's about the involvement of
sub-national units on the india side
and why their involvement could make a
difference
so i'm i'm really saying
don't
just talk about things at the level of
bargaining chips it's too
broad
pick a couple of bargaining ships that
you think are most promising and say who
should do what
with this new bargaining chip that might
lead to
either a new treaty or
better administration of the existing
treaty
or
a completely different kind of treaty
i mean not keep the one you have
and in addition
adopt maybe a new treaty about this
additional river
maybe that's what opens things but but
take specific bargaining chips and make
them into your recommendations okay
okay thank you yeah so in line with
larry's succession so my suggestion
would be um
so you mentioned only the estate versus
state um
diplomacy but you know the um india's
water um resource responsibility is
given to the um
uh is given to the estate i mean not
federal state so um most uh
mass of the water power is given to the
state i mean west bengal state has the
power for managing water resources
in the west bengal so the central
government cannot intervene anything
regarding the
decision of the west bengal's water
resources uh issues so in that case um
the um
one of the key stakeholders would be the
west bengal and i i mean you know the
how how the um this the water treaty
didn't work although the central
government
was agreed with the bangladesh
government but because of the
west bengal government uh it didn't
happen so i think this um as larry
mentioned if we can incorporate or you
can incorporate the um
uh
the state as as a stakeholders
maybe that can also uh important and uh
i think that is essential not important
because without a study you cannot
negotiate with the central
government
so this is on point and in terms of um
identifying issues already if you um
ask some of the people's key peoples uh
they need to be easier for um
you so you already identified several
issues one of the issues is the um is
bangladesh is concerned regarding the
climate sense and its impact on the
future uh river flow
and
so this is one of the key aspect but
also other respect for the new soul game
um you already mentioned the
incorporating how the seven sisters and
um
the transit
bangladesh can help achieving this um
this uh yeah the the new
uh water treaty that that incorporates
the the
the future uh ensuring future
reward flow but but also
you know the last few years there was a
discussion for developing a um paris in
the
ganges in the within the bangladesh part
which
india um denied and with india opposed
and that
plan has been
uh heard the deep sea base the deep sea
base
not deep sea uh berries in the uh
yeah the freshwater flow
uh berries in the bangladesh to store uh
fresh water for for
for uh southwest part of the bangladesh
so this kind of option clear creation
can be helpful for for treaty
negotiations so i i
believe if you can ask some of the
people's that i already mentioned to you
if you interview them i think you can
have more much more insight but for the
paper you might not consider them given
the time limit but as larry mentioned if
you consider only two or three specific
points that can be helpful for
incorporating someone could be the
climate sense other
uh could be the engaging stakeholders
like state level
stakeholders and and the interacting
with the um seven system for the transit
and how this can help
treaty negotiations so this kind of
uh this is specific aspects you can
consider
thank you very much